Researchers have uncovered evidence
of a Neolithic skull cult at an important
archeological site in southeastern Turkey.
They found skull fragments with unique markings
buried among the earliest known examples
of monumental buildings--
sometimes called "the world’s first temples"
Since there were markings on fragments
from three different skulls
and they were found in the context of the
Gobekli Tepe site, for which a clear
ritual component is proposed,
researchers believe that
these fragments could be evidence
of the presence of a ‘skull cult’.
A skull cult means people were modifying,
decorating and displaying skulls
in a ritual context.
Other decorated skulls have been found
at other Neolithic sites in the Middle East but
this is the first such find at Gobekli Tepe
Here, the bodies were buried,
the skulls occasionally exhumed
and stripped of any remaining flesh.
Subsequently, skulls could be decorated with paint
or facial features remodelled in clay.
Analysis of the new fragments
revealed cut marks in the skulls
left over from the defleshing process,
as well as deep grooves
made with flint tools and puncture holes.
These incisions and holes
are a type of skull modification
that hasn’t been seen before in this region
and suggest that the skulls were strung up
as decoration.
It’s too soon to tell whether these skulls
were marked as a way to honor ancestors
or punish fallen enemies.
Researchers will be back this fall
to look for more clues to the rituals,
more skulls and the missing skeletons.